[Music]
this talk's title maybe falls a little
bit outside of the
range of of the other talks of today um
and that's because mostly i've been
uh a user
of uh ml platforms uh even though i've
been involved in in building or
approving upon
some of them and so um i'm gonna talk
about that through that
lens which i hope will be interesting to
sort of spark conversation discussion
about
um gaps that are still to be filled in
many common platforms today
you know obviously the the question that
i'm sure you all have great answers to
is what is an ml platform
uh lifting the description from uh data
council's website
uh you know the mlp platform is about
moving systems from development to
deployment um
and the tooling that makes this an
organic process i highlighted
organic here because i think it's really
interesting um
to think about the quality of data
platforms based on
how organic of a process they make model
development
and release to be uh you can
really see that check similar to
engagement metrics for other products
a lot of what a data platform does is
just reduce
friction um at various points of funnel
training model back testing
et cetera and so
um i thought uh so based on
my experience uh previously leading ml
projects
and being on team that have used our
platforms
it'd be interesting to have a humble
user of your email platforms and
some highlights of you know feature gaps
that might still be interesting
so what i want to cover is a little bit
more about
the surface area of ml platforms i think
you know in the talks today you saw that
there's really a wide range of uh
what you can consider to be part of ml
platform for sort of like
model orchestration with things like
angelo tools to prevent time traveling
and data
leakage and online feature stores um
which i believe zipline helps with
and uh sort of also just
general orchestration of all these
workflows and putting them all together
in a coherent
uh hole then i'll i'll highlight sort of
five areas uh offline data management uh
mostly you know within the lens of
training models as opposed to just a
data management
uh validating model performance
deploying models uh what happens after
you deploy models which
sort of like both encompasses um
monitoring and alerting
and preempting errors
so going back to to ml platforms this is
uh you know a sketch i
i made of what are all the areas that i
think
are are covered by ml platforms you can
see that there's anything from
continuous integration
um to purely application logic
uh especially around sort of like output
validation
um and and sort of uh feeding the right
data set to a model but also monitoring
model inputs model outputs monitoring
latency etc
there's various such graphs online this
is from
the great paper uh hidden technical
depth in machine learning systems
would recommend this favorites by google
if you haven't read it it's it's
really solid um and this is their sort
of graph
of um what is nl platform what i find
interesting is that they highlight the
machine learning code right this is very
small subset in the middle here
and that you have all these giant
systems actually are doing most of the
heavy lifting
as some of you are well aware of i'm
sure
i think one one takeaway from this is
that uh most machine learning products
aren't about the ammo at all and in fact
most of the surface area
of animal application is is not the
model
that means two things that i think are
important to realize
one is actually most of the problems
will emerge outside of the model
uh you know when things go horribly
wrong at inference time
it's often not the case that the model
is wrong in some way it's the case that
some assumption
a long uh the sort of data flow is
broken
and that that leads to a model breaking
or that leads to
some results being deployed displayed
and uh displayed in an
odd uh manner the other observation is
that that means it's
easier to fix the overarching system the
platform itself
um than the model in fact you know when
you have
had sort of like incidents and
productions where you know like some
models performing poorly
uh if you've ever been involved with
that you'll know that very rarely
the solution is to retrain the model and
redeploy it one because that's
costly and uh takes a lot of time
especially when you want to respond to
innocent quickly
but two because usually for for most
serve battle tested models you have many
ways to
recover from from a model failing and
i'll talk about some of those ways later
so starting with offline data management
i think one sort of interesting
um use case of mmo platforms is how they
how they fast facilitate the the
relationship between models and data
so you know if you think about the the
graphite at the start well
this is mostly related to how do you
backtest models and evaluate them
ml models don't exist without data sets
so making
um data gathering uh iteration on data
sets feature generation and mod
evaluation easy
is sort of part of the the contract of
of
a platform that supports them out
as again many of you i'm sure know
a model is sort of tied to its data set
um the bottom right i have an example of
you know a simple model but that is
uh represents a phenomenon that
basically exists everywhere which is
that
if you train a model in this example on
trying to forecast
the volume of rain and you you train it
on you know
data from san francisco if you do
inference in seattle that model will do
really poorly
and so each model should be tied to a
data set uh
usually this is something that data
scientists
you know do themselves they write in
their jupiter notebook that this is like
the result of data from this range from
this query that maybe they've copy
pasted
um and that it was that future version a
lot of ml platforms
you know rightly so try to try to
automate some of that
and to to make not only the
feature list the date range and the
future versions explicit
um but i think what i found is even when
those things are true when for a given
model you have this sort of like
let's say like a shot of the feature
version and a date range and a feature
list
you still oftentimes have the problem
that even though you
have the artifacts or rather the ledger
of what that training run was it is
actually very hard to rerun the same
model
and so there's actually a central
failure point which is if for some
reason you
you even lose the binary file of your
model
it should be sort of
feasible to automatically retrain the
same model on the same data
with the same feature list so that very
quickly becomes very hard um
right because maybe the features have
changed and you've deprecated some
some versions of them and so that i
think is still a challenge currently
similarly um you know
data sets change constantly especially
in industry you reside you realize that
some of your features are wrong
you know you want to add some features
you want to improve upon some features
and i think that that's also an area
where most
ml platforms have made it so much easier
to
um take an existing data set and like
process it further or take an existing
data set and join it with some other
data
that some other team is using and use it
to enrich your own models
one area uh that i think is still really
promising to explore and hasn't been
explored much
is sort of capturing new events to
derive features from
all you know features um
eventually come either from some
transactional data or from some logging
that you do at some point in the
pipeline and that means that if you want
to add a new feature oftentimes you want
to like
add a new logging system uh verify that
you're logging the right thing
wait for those logs to propagate all the
way generate a training set
um and then train a model on it but
feature exploration by its nature
is work where you don't know um
what the impact of a feature will be and
so i think making it easier
to test with less investment whether a
potential feature would be good
is actually a really valuable part of
the workflow as well
finally on data management i think
another like common uh
pain point of data scientist and
interesting directions i've seen
platforms take is
uh sharing representations
this is an example from stitchfix style
shuffle
where one t mesh stitch has essentially
like a
a tinder for um for clothes where you
say oh i like this stuff i don't like
this top
and that model creates embeddings that
they then propagate for other teams to
use
you know in basically any other ml
application that they that they
want and that empowering that kind of
application is super powerful
and takes a a data store that can store
something that's maybe like a little bit
odd right which is allowing the storage
of arbitrary vectors keyed on arbitrary
features so that they can be shared
i think this is something that has
started to happen more and more uh but
that can really enable some
cross-functional work
so all in all for for data storage i
think it's interesting to think
uh of data sets as sort of like a
reproducible feature of a model
meaning fully reproducible um and so a
model being fully trainable on this new
feature
um and having that having not only the
raw data but any intermediary
representations including feature
vectors being shared
with other teams
maybe more interestingly and and more um
at the intersection of mlm platforms i
want to talk about performance
validation
so again you have models uh and you know
you train them and usually you back test
them
and that's how you decide whether you're
going to release a new model
earlier today you know zipline talked
about for example like preventing time
traveling
i think one thing that's that's
interesting here is
even though um in regular software you
can have
like thorough tests and be relatively
confident that your application will
work
that's not the case in ml you can have
all of your tests passing and somehow
you ship your model and it's still bad
and one of the main reasons for that
again is uh data leakage if you use
production data
it's almost impossible to prevent time
travel
and so a lot of land architectures like
zipline or like
uh semblance at stripe uh address this
by using event streams
in order to recompute what the state of
the world was
um at a given time i think those
abstractions are very powerful but i
wanted to use this time to just
call out that they can never
make data leakage uh disappear entirely
i'll give you an example of
sort of my my favorite pet peeve which
is uh
separating separating data randomly uh
what is commonly done
for testing a model right is you take 30
of your data
you take it you separate it randomly
from the rest of your data uh you train
a model in 70
and you test it on the hell of 30 it
turns out that even if you're given
a data set with no time traveling um
but it has for example a date range if
you perform a random split then the
model you produce
will have data leakage if somehow your
data contains duplicates
uh you're you'll have data leakage um
and if you have somehow multiple
measurements
for uh sort of like a unique customer
or a unique uh embedding you'll also
have data leakage and that will lead to
your offline measure measurement
overestimating the performance of your
model
and then that will lead to you deploying
your model and being very sad
i call that out because even though it's
great that we have tools to
to sort of reduce the the burden of the
practitioner
and make it harder to make these kinds
of mistakes the real way that you can
tell whether your model is working well
is by deploying it and
the way to make that uh the way to make
that evaluation easier to make that
process smoother
uh here i sketched out sort of the
difficulty
of or or the risk of the evaluation of a
model compared to its accuracy so the
least accurate method is the held out
test set that we just talked about
um but it's also not risky at all
slightly more risky because you're
increasing load on your
on your production systems is to run the
model in shadow mode where it's scoring
uh but you're actually just throwing its
predictions away you're not using a new
production app
but that is much more accurate because
then you'll see features as they come in
and you'll be able to actually
accurately
accurately compute its performance and
finally the most accurate
is to run a model in production also
obviously the most risky
you should not start with that step but
i think the the interesting thing is
some of the tools that have
made the most meaningful changes to
workflows are the ones that actually
allow you to seamlessly go
from one to the other uh from from one
part of this graph to the other right so
that you can simply promote a model
shadow see if it's doing well
um if it's doing well do you feel recipe
uh confidence to
to run into production and if it's not
doing a lot of pressure in shadow it's
easy to take it back and you see it to
roll back
um and that's actually in some ways much
more helpful than trying to nail down
the last ten percent of sort of data
leakage issues that could arise
so yeah i guess the takeaway of this is
instead of trying to reduce data leakage
entirely with with sort of like
preventing time traveling at future
store
uh or instead of eliminating it try to
reduce it instead
model deployment is the bottom part of
this graph i think it's interesting for
for
two main reasons one is
to many ml folks before they've worked
in industry for a bit model deployment
seems like the simplest problem in the
world
right you train a model uh and then you
you save the binary
and then you load the binary but
as as you know as i'm sure you've seen
today uh
it's a little bit more complicated than
that right there's different model
versions uh which date was the model
trained on
what version of the data matters um did
you filter out
any particular uh user regions or any
particular criteria that would make your
model
not apply well to to these particular
users
um this is something that automation
obviously helps with a lot
you can add sort of arbitrary um you
know
in this graph i add like the
pre-processing as something that
is also uh hard to keep track of and if
you
start deploying manually um or if you
don't have a tool to help you keep track
of that lineage
uh it's very common to just ship a model
that's on the wrong feature version on
the wrong app version or with the wrong
pre-processing i've done that before
and those errors are not only common
they're also really hard to debug so
tools that help with that have been
extremely useful
finally i think there's something that i
haven't seen tackled much
and that might have been because i
haven't looked at the right areas but
almost every model i've ever trained and
shipped
has suffered from some version of
stillness you know if you're predicting
click for ads
or if you're um trying to
predict demand for for for any product
or if you're trying to detect fraud
patterns in the world change and so you
need to retrain your model every
10 days every and months every and hours
um usually this retraining at least for
a while is done manually
um actually usually it's just not done
until somebody notices that the model is
going to completely stale
and then they retrain it but this is
something that could be fully automated
and in fact
knowing things like what is the optimal
uh
retraining period how long should we
wait until we retrain to balance
the inherent risk of rolling out a model
and the staleness of the current model
is something that that would be really
helpful to have as a as a first-class
citizen of web
platforms
so again two points helping with version
versioning
and helping with automatic redeploys is
something that
is probably the most toilsome aspect of
of model deployment for humans currently
and that anal platforms can and should
do well
monitoring and alerting is maybe even
more important
uh here and and this is by design i've
gone from maybe the
the most benign to the most important
aspects in my opinion
so monitoring you know comes with you
ship a model uh in theory everything
goes well in practice
uh it doesn't because that's just uh the
rule of engineering and of machine
learning engineering specifically
there's many reasons why you know a
model could fail to perform production
i've i've put three here that are common
or that have been common in my
experience which is
somehow your input distribution changes
um
somehow some part of of your your model
causes an increase in the latency or
um everything looks fine but also your
output distribution seems to change and
that indicates that maybe something is
wrong with the model itself
these bugs happen uh you know i don't
say they happen on every model release
but they happen frequently on some model
releases
and as the person has been tasked to
debug them i found that
while automation helps with uh releasing
models
it can be really hard to debug what's
going wrong
when all you're given is an alert of you
know the
the mean score output of your model used
to be 0.4 and now it's 0.2
um there's no there's no significant
difference
in the statistical distribution of your
input data
what is wrong and what's been the most
helpful for those is their regular
inspection points
where you can look at your data when
it's coming in raw you can look at it
after you've
um you know cleaned it you can look at
it after you've generated your features
to try to see if like
somehow some part of your future
generation pipeline you know due to like
for example production change has broken
um and you can look at the features like
right before they're fed to the model
and other predictions of the model right
after they come out of the model before
any further filtering
any system that's allowed me to do that
has saved me hours
uh it is not impossible to debug model
issues without having that sort of
visibility
and it's not always easy to provide it
by default
you know just realizing on tools like
splunk or other like logging tools
doesn't give you the sort of
aggregate views that you sometimes want
to see right sometimes you just want to
say like hey
you know what is the proportion of
um time that this feature is null or
that this feature has this value so
things like tf data validation and
others
other recent advancements have really
helped with that aspect ethics
as a i add this as a as a as
a nice to have on top of
observability alerts can be really
helpful when it comes to helping
ml folks debug models one caveat
of alerts is that if you have
you know an alert on is the proportion
of nulls on this
feature higher than expected let's let's
say that higher than five percent
and you have 400 features um it's hard
to tune a threshold
that will not give you a bunch of false
positives and so a lot of the learning
systems suffer from that where
um you know every day you have 55
feature alerts
and because you have 55 feature alerts
you just sort of learn to to live with
it
and you just ignore them entirely and so
what i found is is tuning thresholds
pretty aggressively at the cost of
missing some alerts
to make sure that you actually have time
to action each alert that comes up
all right and uh one of my my favorite
topics and one that i i haven't seen any
platform handle currently but
that would love for for that to not be
the case anymore
is error preemption and so this is
actually core to the application logic
and i think this is why
ml platforms so far haven't tackled that
aspect as much
because it's very hard to build a
general generalizable
solution so this is maybe more of a pipe
dream than a feasible outcome but i
think it's something actually
causes a huge amount of pain for
engineers and memo engineers and and
could really
reduce toil for many model deployments
and the idea here is that a model
a machine learning model will produce
predictions if it receives
inputs if the data is in the right shape
you know your model will make a
prediction
um at the bottom here you can see an
example uh this is a model that
classifies whether a question is about
language or cooking
i imagine that being used by like stack
overflow or something or
stack exchange which has more general
questions um and you know you have a
sentence
the model transforms it into a vector
then it does uh essentially a bunch of
matrix multiplications
a soft max and it outputs a prediction
if you're in place if you replace that
sentence with you know absolute nonsense
on the right
your model still makes a prediction uh
maybe it's slightly more
uh slightly less confident but it's
still going to make a prediction and
it's true for sort of like any
ml model uh ever right as long as data
is in the right side it'll make
predictions but sometimes
the data data will be of the right size
and will be absolutely wrong
and so how can we know if that is the
case
and how can we sort of proactively
prevent it since we know this is
something that will happen
one thing that that ends up just
happening in practice is that
um somebody at some point in application
code writes some input check
that checks for the presence of feature
it checks for like are they within the
statistical range that we've seen
you know in training and potentially
checks the model score itself to say
like hey is the model
confident or is it sort of like
outputting a 50 50
in terms of its output probabilities and
based on that check
you know usually what you'll do is
you'll run the model if everything looks
good
um if there's still enough information
but you don't have enough to run the
model
sometimes you'll run a heuristic that
can give you some of the value but not
all of it
uh and if it just seems like there's no
way that a model or a heuristic would
succeed
you display an error um
if you think about it there's no reason
that that should be written in
application logic for every single ml
application
this could be something where you just
have a first class or like filtering
block where you define these primitives
um and and they're just handled uh
gracefully that way
to help with that um a lot of ml teams
also have some sort of anomaly detection
right where they like
say hey if this value is is above this
certain threshold then it's probably
anomaly and we can just
outright you know reject it if it's like
in this example like a number of login
attempts for a user
or just not even run our model this is
also something that
that is custom built every time but
doesn't necessarily need to be
and finally one of the approaches that i
find the most elegant and that maybe
is the most suited to ml platforms is an
approach that
is used by by many product teams and one
of the examples is it's explicitly
called out in the google smart reply
paper
which is a paper that's about google's
method um
to propose uh replies for emails if
you've ever
used it in gmail you receive an email
and there's like a few replies that are
suggested to you
um there are some like quick replies
that might apply to this email
uh the model they use to generate those
replies is is actually costly and can
fail on input that
you know like a complex email and so
they have a very simple logistic
regression ahead of it
that classifies the input as is this
the kind of input that the model will
run well on and so it maybe seems
a little recursive where you have a
model to tell you whether you should run
your model
um but running filtering models actually
makes a lot of sense uh in many
practical cases it helps reduce costs
overall
because you can run the super simple
model and then never pay the inference
cost
if um if the filtering model says you
shouldn't
but you can also sort of just guard
yourself against failures of one model
by having two models make that decision
for you
and that's something that also could be
you know facilitated a little more
because usually it's just done
by again hand wiring this like first
model that you've trained and then the
second model then you have to keep in
mind the relationships between both and
when you release one it implies
releasing the other
and that seems something that very much
could be automated and could add
um just a huge amount of lift
so the takeaway of this section is that
model models you know will make errors
and usually application code is written
to surf cache those errors ahead of time
and to make sure that the user
experience is
salvaged but if this is something that
you have to write for every single model
that you'll deploy
ever then it probably makes sense to
have the system that's in charge of
helping you deploy models
have it permitted for you to write it
more easily
all right we've covered a lot um
you know as as always i probably had a
few too many slides but
here's a here's a takeaway slide that i
hope um you know clarifies any any
lingerie questions you may have
uh which is you know if ml platforms are
tools to help manage
inevitable model failures uh then for
each of the below aspects
uh these are likely you know in my
humble again user review
the things that offer the most lift and
um that probably should be first class
citizen in an eml platform
i'm happy to you know share the slides
later i think they'll probably be on
data council's website so you can have a
have a look at them
um but in the meantime you know that's
all i have um
i want to thank you all for for
attending if you have
more questions or if you want just more
sort of ideas about deploying ml or
ml platforms as we mentioned i recently
published a book
you can read its first chapter for free
at that url or reach me on twitter
thanks
[Music]